hi guys Dr Burke here this video we're
going to talk about how to diagnose
nutritional deficiencies Through Your
Eyes the eyes tell it all okay so the
first thing is yellow the whites of the
eyes become yellow or the skin is yellow
that is jaundice so there's a there's
this type of byproduct from bio called
Billy Rubin that backs up through the
liver into the blood and that's why it
turns yellow and that's because
something is obstructing the flow of the
bile duct from that's connected to the
gallbladder so so that's usually a
gallbladder problem so that that tells
us that your diet needs to be changed to
keep the flows going through the B duct
so yellow eyes is liver or gallbladder
okay the next one is bloodshot eyes now
yes this can happen when you drink
alcohol but it's also a vitamin B2
deficiency okay
riboflavin and that usually comes from
consuming too many refined grains breads
pasta cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes things like that so in that
case you want to stop eating those Foods
okay and eat healthy okay that's a B2
deficiency the next one the little
plaing on the eye uh and it could happen
little like little chunks of something
to the eye or it could be the eyelid
that is cholesterol plaing it's a
genetic problem usually where the person
has very high levels of cholesterol and
they just can't seem to get rid of it in
that case what you have to do is you
have to reduce your cholesterol from the
diet unfortunately uh and take a lot of
leathan and choline those are the two uh
B vitamins that help reduce cholesterol
I I would also uh say to consume niin
that would also help lower cholesterol
just to minimize the damage okay the
next one would be cataracts that's where
you have this plaing on the eye this
opaque whiteness that's obstructing
vision and that's a B1 deficiency now
the way way you get a B one deficiency
is either consuming too much sugar being
a diabetic or going through massive
amounts of stress of course also eating
refined grains as well and uh B1 will
cause this cataract okay next one is the
inner eyelid underneath the eyelid it's
all red and irritated it almost feels
like there's sand that is a blood sugar
usually a hypoglycemia or a blood sugar
issue in that case I I put some video
links down below how to deal with the
blood sugar issues but that's really
easy to fix but a lot of um
pre-diabetics have this this Vision
issue and it's all sensitive and
irritated and inflamed okay that's what
it is last one is a little um uh like a
little pimple or a cyst on the eyelid
that's a sty that's also a blood sugar
issue because the white blood cell the
neutrophils uh instead of going after
the bacteria they like to always eat
sugar first so leave leave the bacteria
there they go after the sugar and they
basically become inactivated so nutrifil
are normally there to help eat up and
clean up all this bacteria Well it can't
get rid of that because your sugars are
off so people with sty normally always
consume too much sugar or they have
blood sugar issues okay so again you can
watch the blood sugar video down below
okay well thank you so much for watching
put your comments below and I'll see you
in the next
video